20 secondes après le début du vol, la
propulsion de la première étape est nominale
t plus 30 secondes après le début de cette mission historique
équipage de vol à bord du dragon et du faucon 9
et regardez-les aller à la
puissance du faucon, dites-moi que
nous ralentissons
pour nous préparer pour la période de
pression dynamique maximale
nous sommes dans les rapports du godet d'accélérateur
disent que tous les systèmes sont en marche
[Musique] le
véhicule est supersonique nous avons dépassé
mach 1 sur le falcon 9.
[Musique]
et nous avons entendu qu'un bravo crie
c'est juste la deuxième
zone d'abandon  qu'ils sont là-dedans, ils
continueront à être là-dessus
jusqu'à ce que le premier âge ait fait son travail et
qu'ils passent au second
à ce stade bob et doug tirant environ
2,3 g soit
2,3 fois la gravité terrestre le
déplaçant déjà à
1500 miles  par heure,
nous avons entendu l'appel pour le refroidissement du moteur
mvac qui prépare le moteur
mvac à s'allumer qui arrivera à environ
244 en vol en ce moment tout
continue à bien paraître le
prochain événement majeur à venir
sera le triple
nous aurons la coupure du moteur principal des
neuf moteurs du premier étage, la
séparation des étages, puis l'allumage du
moteur du deuxième étage pour continuer à
transporter les
astronautes en
orbite dans environ 20 secondes.